welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and as we look ahead to Marvel
Phase 5 in 2023 there are still several
unanswered questions from Marvel phase 4
that the MCU teased addressing got so
freaking close to a dress scene but
never actually did address apparently
considering it more of a priority to
establish where the new Asgard is
desensitized enough to a universe-wide
cataclysmic War crime to turn into an
ice cream shop so here are 30 questions
at the top of our minds going into
Marvel phase five many of these
submitted by our wonderful followers on
Twitter and actually some I will start
to answer based on what we know so far
whereas others I will just leave within
number one where are the X-Men and why
is it taking so long phase four did
introduce mutants with Kamala Khan and
neymor but other than a wolverine Easter
egg and She-Hulk and a short-lived
Professor X cameo in Multiverse of
Madness there still ain't any X-Men and
the president MCU though Hugh Jackman
Wolverine is at least confirmed a return
in Deadpool 3. there have been some
unconfirmed rumors of contractual issues
with the fox X-Men actors and that
Marvel might have to wait until after
Secret Wars to recast any of these
characters not really sure how true
those rumors are or really how Fox could
sign such unprecedented Ironclad
contracts with a cast of dark Phoenix I
just think Kevin feige hasn't gotten a
pitch or a producer team he has loved
yet Anna but related number two how does
mutation work in the MCU if Kamala and
Neymar are both mutants presumably both
carry a mutant Gene but what activates
that Gene is it Cosmic radiation is it a
heart-shaped herb received in utero is
it just puberty also who else in the MCU
is actually a mutant wanna maximoff
Monica rainbow mantis number three free
will versus Destiny so after Loki and Ms
Marvel and She-Hulk does Free Will Truly
exist in the MCU well it depends how you
look at it but yes and no he who remains
selected everything that's in the sacred
timeline and has a transcript of it but
he pruned and trimmed down what was
already there from countless histories
that already existed long before him he
wasn't the original writer of it he was
more of a adapted screenplay kind of guy
so if you look at it that way the
Avengers made all the choices they made
freely however other multiversal
Avengers were denied that privilege so
really the infinity Saga Avengers had
free will but only thanks to multiversal
privilege another way of thinking about
this is do you have the career and
education you have because of your own
choices or because your parents were
rich and set you up for it chew on that
related how does time travel work in the
MCU Branch timelines or predestination
well in game and Loki's first five
episodes suggested Branch timelines but
Loki's finale in Ms Marvel suggested
predestination so I'm going to say
predestination for now number five who
are the Avengers right now well the only
Avengers Meetup we really saw in phase
four was the shangshi post credit scene
which means Wong Bruce Banner Carol
Danvers and Chung Chi roady's probably
in that group chat as well probably Sam
Wilson Captain America too but really it
just seems like most of the Avengers are
distracted with other stuff right now so
number six who bought Avengers Tower
after far from home we assume phase four
would answer this question we actually
thought it could be the Fantastic Force
Baxter building but Multiverse of
Madness showed the 838 Baxter foundation
in Central Park others thought it could
be Oscorp Tower but no way home said
there was no Oscorp in the MCU so wait a
minute based on that Loki void episode
depicting it as Kang's King Tower maybe
it was actually sold to the Kang variant
known as Mr Gripen King is coming it's
probably him right okay number seven
without Oscorp what spider bit Peter
Parker actually made a video about this
Peter's Origins do not always have to
connect to Oscar and I think it was a
gamma-radiated spider in an abandoned
Avengers Tower after Age of Ultron and
that is why Tony Stark was tracking
Peter Parker before Civil War number
eight where did white Vision go we saw
him flee Westview in the one division
finale and Vision Quest will show us
where he went I think he either went to
the ruins of that woundigore Temple or
he went to the sword facility to beat
everyone up number nine why is no one
talking about Tiamat yep that's a big
one but hey She-Hulk did reference this
and I did just make a video about it so
I think it's either an adamantium mine
that we will see in Thunderbolts and
Captain America 4 or maybe a new
Avengers Campus number 10 where did
erishim take the eternals he clearly
took them somewhere to judge them for
stopping tiamat's Merchants where does
one go from there I think to appeal to
The Living Tribunal who exists in some
form of see you we saw one version of
Multiverse Madness another in Thor 11
Thunder number 11 Celestial hierarchy so
who outranks whom in the Marvel Cosmos
celestials Kang The Watcher the best
answer we got on this I think were the
seven entities we saw in that door 11
Thunder chamber that included eternity
The Watcher death Eon Infinity The
Living Tribunal and the chief Celestial
that is known as the celestial one above
all I think these seven transcend
realities and they share a tear with
whatever Kang happens to be at the top
of that Kang dog pile at any given
moment I also at this point don't really
know if eternity exists anymore or just
transformed into mistress love and then
Kang might have taken her seat it's hard
to know because well take it away Kate
Hudson this reality now thank you to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video you
remember that moment in game where caps
all alone facing off against Thanos then
everybody shows up to help there is a
reason we all cheered so hard when that
happened someone we love got help and it
was such a relief getting help is good
and now thanks to better help getting
help is easy too better help is the
world's largest therapy service and it's
100 online with better help you can tap
into a network of over 25 000 licensed
and experienced therapists who can help
you with a wide range of issues to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you need and what your
preferences are for therapy that way
better help can match you to the right
therapist from their Network once that
is done you can talk to your therapist
however you feel comfortable whether
it's via text chat phone or video call
you can message a therapist at any time
and schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you if your therapist
isn't the right fit for any reason you
can switch to a new therapist at no
additional charge better help lets you
get the same professionalism and quality
you expect from in-office therapy but
with a therapist who is custom picked
for you with more scheduling flexibility
and at a more affordable price to get 10
off your first month you can scan the QR
our code or click the link in the
description or just go to betterhelp.com
new rockstars that's better
help.com new rockstars for 10 off your
first month of therapy number 12 is
Wanda dead well Kevin feige tease that
she might still be alive in that Rubble
after Multiverse Madness so dig my
admission dig number 13 what about 838
Wanda well I also made a video about
this I think the 838 Universe might
blame this victim Wanda for killing the
Illuminati and we could still get a
house of them storyline that way number
14 who were the 10 Rings summoning I
think they were summoning the Creed or
some other ancient extraterrestrial race
who initially brought them to Earth and
that we will find out in the answer to
this in the Marvels actually related to
this number 15 what is the Bengals
connection to the ten rings I think the
Bengal and the 10 rings have the same
extraterrestrial Cosmic text Source
number 16 where is Old Steve Rogers
Joaquin Torres and Falcon the Winter
Soldier imply that he could be on the
moon I think Steve is either with Nick
Fury in that space station or retired
but either way he's still [ __ ] number
17 who did Steve lose his virginity two
She-Hulk asked the question we did make
a video on it I think the Chicago fan
girl on the USO tour played by Laura
haddock because the camera did take a
picture of them as they met giving a
historical record to this by the way
Laura haddock the same actress who plays
Meredith quill number 18 who gave Agatha
the dark hold I do not think she had it
during the 1693 coven trial I think
Mephisto gave it to her shortly before
Wanda vision and she could not
understand it fully which is why she
needed Wanda's Power number 19 where is
the TVA in the Multiverse I still
believe the TVA is in a timeline neutral
null time zone realm the Loki finale
suggested it was warpable AKA timeline
attached but the Loki season 2 footage
that I saw at d23 suggested that the
Kang Decor was underneath all the
timekeeper decor making it the same
place so I don't think the TVA is any
one particular Universe it's really a
separate realm number 20 who was Jimmy
Woo's witness protection person number
21 where did Jake lockley come from Jake
was the third altar alongside Mark
Spector and Stephen Grant from the
beginning he was that third mystery
off-screen altar who beat up the thugs
in Egypt so he was there the whole time
we just didn't see him until the ending
number 22 where were the Avengers during
t'challa's funeral I also covered this
in another video tldr I think Ramona
just wanted a private wakandan ceremony
not all funerals have to be a huge
family and friend reunions number 23 how
powerful exactly is Kevin the robot from
She-Hulk related question was Todd's
intelligencia ever a real threat did
Kevin technically rewrite she-hulk's
preferences well Todd's intelligencia
was never more than a website who
trolled and stalked and harassed Jen
Walters they never actually got her
blood to create Hulk Tai that part was
erased however Kevin remains he's
somewhere between a Nexus being and a
cosmic entity also from She-Hulk
Titania's backstory we never learned why
Titania wrecked that trial in the first
episode my theory was that they
originally planned for Titania to tie
into the Thunderbolts but they ended up
going in a different direction and they
removed that subplot when they
restructure the pilot 25 who's a
squirrel we're gonna find out secret
Invasion but probably Roadie number 26
did Monica Rambo already have her powers
I think she did we are going to learn
why and why she's so awkward around
Carol Danvers in the Marvels number 27
why is Groot swole I made a video about
this my explanation is that Groot is a
flora Colossus who feeds on photonic
knowledge and I think he's been
absorbing Celestial light from quill and
mantis light that his ancestor the
previous adult group when the first
Guardians did not have number 28 where
did rensslayer go well in search of free
will she says we'll find out Loki season
two but I suspect she's getting out of
Dodge because the incoming kangs will
not honor whatever separation agreement
she's signed with ex-boyfriend he
remains number 29 where is Venom now we
saw that goo left behind and no way home
post great scene I think he is
inchwarming his way to Peter Parker so
that we'll get black suit Peter in
secret Wars but speaking up Peter number
30 who the hell is this guy no seriously
how does Doctor Strange's memory wipe
spell work Strange's spell only affected
people's memories of Peter when he was
unmasked so everyone still remembers
Spider-Man they just don't remember the
Peter Parker underneath the mask
everything Spider-Man did is still part
of history and people still remember
Spider-Man being the hero there they
just don't know who Spider-Man is
everyone just thinks of him as a mystery
Mass Village Landing still but I think
that spell only affects people in this
reality as Wong said the roots of cop
call affects the borders of known in
unknown reality so there you go that's
30 questions that we would love phase
five to clarify for us it's okay if my
answers are wrong I just need answers
let me know if you had other questions
that were not on this list and you can
subscribe to new Rockstar's new channel
the Deep dive that is launching February
17th in which I will be digging even
deeper into a few select titles of the
more appointed investigatory Focus
Channel handle and on all socials at
Deep dive NR you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
me rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for breakdowns and theories of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
foreign
[Music]